hello and welcome to the take with
safety Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster well the decision's
been a long time coming but finally the
United States Germany and other European
nations will now send battle tanks to
Ukraine while President zlinski heard
some of that news while speaking to
Skies K Burley earlier and with a
Russian offensive expected in the spring
the question now is whether it will be
enough we're back at home Nadim zahawi
is still in his job despite paying
millions in back taxes and a penalty to
hmrc but he might not feel any more
secure after today's pmqs we'll talk
Scandal and substance as we bring you
takes from all sides over the next 60
minutes
leopard two tanks are coming from Europe
you must be relieved
shiny
ah sorry secretary
well that was the moment president
zelinski speaking to our own Kay Burley
in cave today as he heard the news of 14
German tanks on the way and later
another 30 from the U.S were announced
we'll play more of that interview in
this program but back in the comments
you can't even deal with tax avoiders in
his own cabinet yeah yeah is he starting
to wonder if this job is just too big
for him
see what he's doing there no surprises
kierstama focusing on Nadine zahawi at
pmqs today this was Rishi sulak's
response
when anti-Semitism ran right when his
predecessor sided with our opponents
that's what's weak Mr Speaker he has no
principles and just Petty policy well
there were plenty of other very
important questions raised which we will
cover this evening not least the state
of the probation service in this country
and hundreds of missing Asylum seeking
children on the program today we are
going to be talking to the work and
pension secretary Mel stride
from labor or talk to the shadow
Northern Ireland secretary Peter Kyle
and we'll be talking to the former
police chief constable and independent
anti-slavery commissioner Dame Sarah
Thornton plus Much More Much More
besides on the take
[Music]
hello good evening well it's another
very significant day in the war in
Ukraine the United States is sending 31
of its Abrams battle tanks to Ukraine
President Biden announced the move after
Germany's decision to send some of its
own leopard two tanks and also allowing
other European countries to do the same
well delays to that decision by Berlin
had put NATO Unity under strain with
President salenci you can see him there
talking to our own at K Burley pushing
for more tanks more quickly
president zelensky was talking to Kay
when he found out the German tanks were
on the way
leopard two tanks are coming from Europe
you must be relieved
uh
um
no
thank you anymore
[Music]
to Washington we can speak to our U.S
correspondent uh Mark Stone so the U.S
is Sunday more thanks to Ukraine but we
just heard there president zelinski
saying the delivery time is critical
what's the time frame for this
a month Sophie uh even the uh the best
case scenario which is for the uh German
tanks or at least the the German
manufactured tanks that may be operated
by other Eastern European countries
those will be the first to arrive and
I'm told from sources here in Washington
uh that the expectation is that they
won't arrive for several months so
around about the time when the spring
offensive the Russian spring offensive
is expected as for the American tanks uh
well they will be months and months and
months away perhaps even up to a year
away there's no expectation that they
will be ready in time for any Russian
spring offensive the reason for that is
because the Americans are procuring them
they're not taking them from existing
U.S army stocks for reasons that they
haven't gone into but I think maybe some
of that is going to be to do with um
sophisticated
um the sophisticated nature of these uh
the most modern version of the M1 Abrams
Tanks they're going to want to provide a
different version because there is a
concern as there has been all along but
it is a very real concern with tanks
which are at the Forefront literally at
the front of any battle that these tanks
if they're damaged will then end up
Behind Enemy Lines and get into the
wrong hands so the American procurement
process will be long they're literally
going to the manufacturers perhaps even
going uh to other countries that they've
sold these tanks to in the past to get
them back and then to provide them to
the ukrainians we're talking many many
months for the um European tanks sooner
but still a long time well up to a year
for the U.S tax I mean that feels like a
pretty important footnote doesn't it and
what about the number as well
um is it what president zelenski is
after
no uh president zielinski I mean
throughout this conflict they've always
asked for more than they know they're
going to get um and they've also to be
honest they bake into their requests uh
the the predictable delays and and
squabbles that we have seen amongst the
West over the course of the past week
with tanks we've seen it before
um they've asked for 300 tanks if the
numbers come in the in what we what they
say they're going to give the West that
is then around about 100 tanks will be
available but in months in the months
ahead and not now so so yeah I mean the
footnotes uh the the Nuance below the
headline that is tight Western tanks are
going to Ukraine is it's not going to
happen uh for quite some time and there
are many reasons for that of course
there is the the issues over concern
about Russia's red lines that Putin's
unpredictable red lines how will he
react
um there are issues over Supply chains
as well the American tank is incredibly
sophisticated it needs a supply chain
that stretches all the way back to the
United States that takes time to put in
place so there's an awful lot behind the
headline today that these tanks are
indeed going to to Ukraine and I was
struck too by what President Biden said
here at the White House Sophie he made
quite clear was it pains to point out
that the delivery of these tanks is
should not be seen as a threat to Russia
proper um they want to counter the
Russian narrative that somehow NATO is
on the offensive to attack Russia itself
this is all about defending NATO
defending Ukrainian uh territory so says
um President Biden the difference is and
this is absolutely key is that when
these tanks are on the battlefield they
will change the nature of the conflict
because they are so sophisticated
they're so much better than the Russian
tanks Ukraine within its own country
will be going able to go on the
offensive in a way it has not done at
all throughout this near year-long
conflict thank you very much Mark
bringing some important context to the
headlines Mark Stone there
and you can see that interview with
Ukrainian president zelenski in full in
the morning on Sky News that will be
from 7am tomorrow morning with K Bernie
let's get the view from the government
here shall we a little earlier I spoke
to the work and pension secretary Mel
stride started of course by asking about
that news that more Western tanks will
be sent to Ukraine
well very pleased because this country
has led the way really and two and a
half billion pounds worth of sport last
year and a further similar amount to
come and the first country to pledge
tanks Challenger twos which will be a
very effective resource for the
ukrainians but we do need to get these
uh this Weaponry over there as quickly
as possible there's a collective effort
the German Leopard tank is very
effective and the Abrams from America
will be very effective too and then of
course we've got to train up the
ukrainians to be able to use these in
double quick time so they can get them
out of the battle Battlefield as fast as
possible and president zelenski has done
an interview with Kay Burley and he said
that overall I'm very thankful to the
world for this support for Ukraine but
speaking frankly the number of tanks and
the delivery time to Ukraine is critical
I mean he obviously thinks that look
pledging the tanks is the easy bit but
it's getting them over there that's
difficult I mean how long could it take
well as I said I'm no expert
unfortunately on how long it will take
the Germans or the Americans to get that
Hardware over there but clearly he's
absolutely right this new to happen at
PACE if we are to get them into place
not just get them into place but get the
ukrainians trained up on how to use what
is certainly in the case of the leopard
and uh I think the Abrams is very
sophisticated tank so there's quite a
job to do to train people up to use
these and that's why he's absolutely
right we need to get this stuff over
there as quickly as possible and the
Kremlin has come back to say these tanks
will burn down like all the others and
the Russian Embassy in Berlin has
reacted to Germany's decision saying
it's an extremely dangerous one and an
escalation of the conflict is there a
risk it provokes well Russia has been
using this language of course right from
the beginning of what is an illegal
invasion of Ukraine which has brought
huge misery to its people and we need to
really see this through and we know that
the Russians are now looking to recruit
hundreds of thousands of additional
reserves to bring in as the weather
changes with as we approach the spring
so we've got to be ready for that so
this kind of rhetoric is is nothing new
I'm afraid but our resolve must be
absolute I was interested Johnson in
Ukraine again on Sunday meeting
President zelenski how do you feel about
the former prime minister still being
the face of the UK's relationship with
Ukraine well he is one part of the UK's
face as you put it and of course I think
one has to
um applaud what Boris Johnson did in
making sure that our country was right
in the Vanguard of supporting Ukraine in
its darkest hour we were one of the
first countries to step up to the plate
and you know he clearly feels very
passionate about this and he's over
there lending his uh his moral support
and so on he's very close to president
zielinski so I think that's very
positive and that doesn't detract of
course from what the government is doing
and what this prime minister is doing
who is equally committed to making sure
that we stand by Ukraine and its people
I'm interested to talk to you about your
brief but just before we do and the
prime ministers asked his new ethics
advisor to investigate whether Nadine
zahari broke the ministerial code how
longer expect that to take I don't know
the answer to that but I do know that
they won't and he won't want to hang
around albeit that he will want to be
very thorough so we're talking weeks
come weeks rather than I really don't
know but I I I I I think in in a
reasonable period of time I think this
is something that one way or another we
need to have closure on the Prime
Minister will want to know all the facts
so that when he gets those facts he's in
a position to take a decision whatever
that may be
um but we do need to leave the the
ethics advisor to do his work and make
sure that it is thorough and that all
the facts are presented to the Prime
Minister when you say they're um about
the Prime Minister taking the decision
so if Laurie Magnus finds that Nadeem
zahawi did breach the ministerial code
we'll reduce you next second I think
that would be a very difficult finding
but I can't and it wouldn't be right for
me to attempt to pre-judge the outcome
of this based on hypotheticals we don't
know what the findings will be and until
we do I think we have to wait for those
to come forward and then wait to decide
to see what the the Prime Minister
designs when you say difficult finding
what do you mean by difficult finding
well clearly no Minister will want to be
in a position where they're found to be
in breach of the ministerial code but as
to the consequences of any particular
outcomes a I can't predict what those
would be and it'd be wrong for me to
speculate and B it wouldn't be right for
me to try and prejudge the prime
minister's decisions based on
theoretical outcomes I guess the
difficulty is that you know we're being
asked to be quiet until the inquiry uh
reports we don't know how long that's
going to be and also for public
confidence in the inquiry surely it's
important to say that everything's on
the table that if he's found a breach of
the code then there'll be consequences
well as I say safety I I'm not in a
position to start speculating as to what
may or may not be established but I
think the prime minister is doing
exactly the right thing which was when
he became aware of additional
information that wasn't available to him
at the time that he appointed in the
deems a highway to the cabinet he took
prompt action in appointing his advisor
and asking him to establish the facts
and that's what that advice will do we
shouldn't rush him in in that endeavor
because the most important thing is that
it's done thoroughly but I know that the
Prime Minister will then look at those
facts very carefully and decide what he
decides to do I think it would be would
you agree it would be difficult if have
you say difficult if the inquiry does
find a breach of the code for the prime
minister to allow Nadine's heart to
sustain his job no I didn't say that
what I said was that if we had a
situation where any minister or indeed
any parliamentarian of any party finds
himself in a position where they breach
the ministerial code then of course
that's a difficult situation but it
depends on what it's for on the degree
and so on and so forth but as I say come
back to the substantial point which is
that we have to let the advisor now
carry out his work have a thorough uh
checking of all the facts presenting
those facts to the Prime Minister and
the Prime Minister then taking his
decision is there an argument that all
high profile politicians members of the
cabinet should publish their tax returns
I don't personally think so
um because I think there are some things
in life which are justifiably a private
medical records for example would be
part of that as well even if they're you
know you're the guys deciding how much
tax everyone else should pay though is
there not a different degree well there
is a a procedure that the cabinet office
goes through when the prime minister is
forming his or her cabinets and those
kind of issues of propriety and ethics
so on it's a bit questionable effects
well yes I mean well well they are drawn
together for a variety of different
means including conversations with the
prospective cabinet uh uh Minister him
or herself so it is part of a process so
I I do think those things matter but do
I think that politicians generally
should be
um sort of summons to publish all their
tax Affairs their financial affairs or
their health
records or whatever else it may be I
think I think there is a limit to what
we should expect public figures to but
others have different views on that
um now there have been a lot of reports
this week talking to you with your
minister of hat on yeah about a plan to
raise the state retirement age to 68.
what's going on what's the truth well uh
the the truth of the matter is is as it
has been for some time now which is that
it is my responsibility to look at
taking that decision in conjunction with
others looking at the various reports
that have been around that issue and
taking into account a whole balance of
different elements when I come to that
decision including how long people are
expecting to live going forward into the
future and how that's changing Through
Time intergenerational fairness impact
on different protected groups and so on
and I will be coming forward with that
decision as I'm statutorily required to
no later than May of this year so that's
work that I'm actively considering at
the moment according to these reports
Jeremy Hunter Charles wants to bring the
retirement age forward and so it wants
to raise the retirement age which makes
sense because it means that you know he
gets more money in the treasury you
apparently are worried about the plan
but potentially because of a fall in
life expectancy projections would make
it politically unfeasible according to
report is that according to reports
whose reports
and find out the truth well as I say I I
can't say any more and in fact it would
be totally improper for me to start
speculating as to where I might want
this to land okay considering the
evidence I've set out the basis I'm
going to have one more go one more
previous reports have said that people
should spend roughly a third of their
life retired do you think that's right I
think that's one of the metrics amongst
many others that one considers when
looking at this decision how long would
you is it reasonable for somebody to
have uh later on in life as a proportion
of their expected their life expectancy
but it's only one element of it and as I
say attempting there though it is uh I'm
not going to start you know being drawn
into okay specific thoughts understood
now when we last spoke we talked about
your efforts to try and get more people
back into work yeah I know that's a big
part of what you're doing yes including
the over 50s many of whom have taken
early retirement I guess my question is
if you don't have to work why would you
well one of the reasons why people over
the age of 50 but below retirement age
step out of the workforce is they've
taken a calculation that they've got
enough assets and income and money to
see themselves through perhaps indeed to
the rest of their lives but what we know
is that if you were born in 1970 you've
got a reasonable chance of reaching 100
in reasonable health so I think there is
therefore a possibility that some of
those that have taken that decision
would benefit from additional
information so you're saying that
they've made the wrong calculation well
yeah I think it's important that
everybody that makes a calculation does
it based on as much information as
possible and they they go into that with
their their eyes open so I think there
may be scope going forward for providing
more of that information so people can
make a more informed choice we have
actually seen a slight decrease in
economic inactivity more recently and a
lot of that has been amongst the over 52
perhaps are beginning to think about
those things particularly as times have
been a bit tougher okay thank you very
much for being on the program thank you
I'll stride at talking to me a little
earlier well we're joined as usual by
our Deputy political editor some coats
for his take we heard that Mouse tried
welcoming uh the extra tanks being sent
to Ukraine I think that way much of a
difference
um it's hard to say for all of the
reasons that I thought came out
extremely clearly in your interview with
male stride it's not clear when they
come and what the impact will be it it
struck us quite a moment actually when
Kay Burley was talking to president
zielinski that was the seemed to be the
second that he had it confirmed that
these these tanks were coming and it's a
coup for K to be over uh uh in Ukraine
talking to president zielinski but
what's interesting is he has to keep up
momentum because one of the big
questions for him just as a big question
here in Westminster is how long this
grinding conflict go goes on for now he
has to keep up the interest of the West
to continue to supply him with a kind of
Munitions that he wants in order to
fight the Russians but also it's a
question for Westminster policymakers
because the duration the ongoing
duration of the war with Russia by
Ukraine has an impact on gas supplies
and inflation and that has a knock-on
effect on the public finances and how
much money that Jeremy Hunt and Michigan
have to spend and and this is all quite
a big deal I want to pick up on his
comments on azim zahawi as well I asked
him look if he's found to be in breached
the code will he get sacked and he said
that would be a very difficult finding
what did you make of that I I feel like
I sort of know what what's going to
happen if the ministerial advisor
concludes that uh Nadim zahar we had to
pay back money to hmrc and he was fined
he will be sacked so as it were those
that's what's been suggested in the
media including by Sky News if that is
verified he's gone how long will Mel
stride said to you it'll take a
reasonable period of time I understand
that could be up to three weeks now
that's what people around Nadim zahawi
have been suggesting to to some which
she feels an incredible amount of time
for something where you should be able
to establish the facts pretty quickly
but the bottom line is nobody including
Rishi sunak is defending Nadine's of
Halloween in public and I think that's
because providing that there are no
surprises in the facts that are out
there he's a goner yeah it did feel that
way I have to say after speaking to Mel
stride very cautious uh person usually
in the interviews her saying it'll be a
very difficult finding uh Sam always
interested to hear your intelligence
there
you're watching a take we are live here
in Westminster up next we are going to
be hearing from Labor's Peter Carr
[Music]
I think that you know it's incredibly
important that we deal with the issue of
climate these days you know which is not
only to do with the planet but harming
enormous number of people on the planet
and the big question is what we can
effectively do and the biggest resource
that normal people have is where their
money goes and our banks where we're
investing our money are in fact huge
investors in fossil fuels but
particularly fossil fuel expansion so
the top you know High Street banks have
given 140 billion to companies that are
expanding fossil fuels and we know that
if we're going to keep the temperature
down you can't have expansion you can't
have new things the banks should be
putting all that money into you know
Wonderful renewable uh energy and
affordable housing and all the good
things that they could be spending for
but they're not behind our facts they're
actually investing in just the things
that we all don't want to happen if you
talk to people they think that Banks
need to do more and most people think
that the bank shouldn't be investing in
fossil fuel expansion so yeah we're just
trying to
forcefully prod you know we've got
Greenpeace save the children Emma
Thompson Deborah Mead and everybody who
we wrote to said this sounds absolutely
right the bank should know that their
clients want them to be on the side of
solving the problem not sort of sneaking
around behind our backs investing in
things which are gonna you know leave a
ghastly situation for our children I
mean we're just seeing climate change
and it's tragedies all around us and we
have the power by saying to our banks
let's actually get out of this stuff to
really make a decisive change you know
if you're recycling if you're throwing
away if you're not using plastic bottles
uh if you're you know all of those
things do this too
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello welcome back it's been a momentous
day with that decision by both the US
and Germany to send battle tanks to
Ukraine joining the UK which has pledged
14 Challenger 2 vehicles but there's
been plenty more happening this week as
well
breaking news the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak has asked his independent ethics
advisor to look into then Adam zahawi
tax case
since I commented on this matter last
week more information has come forward
[Applause]
and that is why I have asked the
independent advisor very idea that he
can be discussing and negotiating his
own tax affairs with the body that he's
supposed to be running everybody knows
its role the chairman of the BBC has
asked for a review into his own
appointment after claims that he helped
the former prime minister Boris Johnson
secure an 800 000 pound loan this is a
load of complete nonsense absentence he
knows absolutely nothing about my
personal finances I can tell you that
for for 100 Ding Dang sure this is just
another example of the BBC disappearing
up its own fundament we had a discussion
with the cabinet secretary about
avoiding conflict and the perception
conflict I felt comfortable and I still
feel there was no there was no conflict
the government says it is investigating
claims that children seeking asylum in
the UK have been abducted from a hotel
in Brighton if one child who was related
to one of us in this room went missing
the world would stop but in the
community I represent a child has gone
missing then five went missing then a
dozen went missing then 50 went missing
and currently today
76 are missing and nothing is happening
there's an awful lot of news happening
at the minute lots of stories dominating
the agenda but I did just want to pick
up on the very end of the Montage that
you just saw and the story about the 200
now Asylum seeking children who are
missing you can get Labor's uh take now
with a man you just heard from the party
Shadow Northern secretary Peter Carl and
thank you for coming on the program
today
um it's a shocking story isn't it just
just explain what's happening well with
two hours notice 96 unaccompanied child
migrants are placed in a hotel in Hove
the minister said yesterday that they
had special Arrangements that they had
special facilities there was no special
facilities there the children were just
left there in very chaotic circumstances
the children did everything that was
asked of them it's slightly chaotic
organization around them I contacted
Sussex police I contacted Social
Services the council and the home office
the only organization that actually
understood the urgency of the
safeguarding challenges that was posed
by that was Sussex police but they
didn't have the resources or the power
but I got to just be really blunt about
this we've always known that children
are being coerced into crime we know
that disadvantaged kids are some kids
leaving school we understand county
lines operations but this has moved on
now because criminals people who are
running criminal gangs will go to where
vulnerable children are and they have
discovered that there are these hotels
housing dozens of children and they are
outside they are in the area they're in
the shops nearby and they are preying on
very vulnerable children I wanted and
the labor party wanted to get a 10-year
sentence for any adult that coerces a
child into crime I table that Amendment
on behalf of the labor party and it was
voted down by the Tories three years ago
I think we need to revisit this because
what I want to do and what the labor
party wants to do is to make children
repulsive to criminals because right now
they are disposable assets it's really
um I mean you speak very powerfully
about about it and in particular the
case you know in your own constituency
as well and so I guess is it part of the
criminal networks that we're seeing you
know obviously we know there's a lot of
young albanians come to the country
trafficked over by people Smugglers and
are they then being picked up
effectively by criminal gangs in the UK
to what work in cannabis factories or
whatever it is well it doesn't matter
what nationality they are they go for
vulnerability so we know that there are
certain places where young people who
are very vulnerable go to sometimes it's
pupil referral units sometimes it's
support centers and youth groups for
children with certain characteristics
and we know that criminal gangs have
actually focused on some of those areas
to try and grab kids and attract kids
when they are leaving those areas well
there's this new thing now and these are
vulnerable kids who come from abroad who
are unaccompanied they're in unregulated
settings they are free to go English is
is not their first language this is a
new culture to them they are
specifically vulnerable sometimes
emotionally extremely vulnerable I've
been inside
this so tell many times I understand
that I've met some of these kids they're
emotionally vulnerable but they are
physically vulnerable to predators to
criminal Predators uh to being coerced
into crime well that's why we need to
make sure for example in this country if
you use a gun as a as a part of your
criminal Endeavor you're going to prison
for 10 years because we have a 10-year
sentence for gun use whatever you're
using it for
in but we don't have anything like that
for children so these these criminals
who are coercing children into crime
usually it's in the drugs trade but for
women and young girls in particular we
know it usually ends up in some kind of
sex trade as well for if you are an
adult who is coercing children into
crime in this way usually you'll get
done for the drugs side of it but you
will not get done and prosecuted usually
for what you've done to the child and I
think what you do to a child when you do
this sort of stuff should be the
headline crime and it should be an
absolutely such a repugnant crime it
should carry a very heavy sentence if
you are a criminal and you coerce
children into criminal Enterprise you
should go away for 10 years and you
should always have the record of what
you've done to a child over your head
for the rest of your life so yeah really
important story we're going to be doing
more on it later on in the program as
well and just to move on to our lead
story today which is a decision by
Germany and the US to pledge battle
tanks to Ukraine and we got president
zelenski's reaction to that as he was
interviewing with Kay now it comes after
the UK was the first Western Country to
pledge tanks do you give the government
a bit of credit we are at least leading
the way when it comes to Ukraine I
absolutely do give the government credit
for it we should be leading the way we
have some of the resources and the
equipment that's needed and we should be
fulsome in the way that we we do so I am
really pleased that Germany's got to
where it has I understand that Germany
has a very very different approach to
these issues this is a very big decision
for Germany to take you know we have
different we were on different sides of
the second world war we both have the
second world war imprinted in our
culture in very very different ways and
I've just pointed out to some people in
the past couple of weeks that when Nazi
Germany invaded invaded Russia 27
million Russians died so in these issues
they they linger very very long there is
a lot of baggage that Germany carries
particularly when the discussion comes
to being offensive and not defensive in
the way that they tackle the defense of
their country so and and use of military
so I'm pleased they got to where they
are it's clear that they've been
thoughtful and it's clear also they've
worked with the US and they've unlocked
some uh investment in tanks from the US
as well so these are all positive things
but we need to see this not as
leadership but partnership Britain has
been very very good and Folsom but we
need to realize that if we're going to
repel Russia and we're going to keep
Russia contained into the future it
can't be one country perceived as
leading we have to work in unison both
with NATO and other European countries
as well and perhaps as well being
prepared to be in it for the long haul I
thought was interesting the kremlin's
response saying these tanks will burn
down just like all the other ones except
they cost a lot and this will fall on
the shoulders of European taxpayers I
mean what would your message be to those
European taxpayers you know it is an
expensive War it is but we understand
that I don't think anybody now truly
believes that if Putin did manage to
Annex all of or invade and occupy all of
Ukraine that he would stop there Moldova
is next then we're on the border of the
European Union with Romania and other
countries none of those countries
themselves believe that that's where he
would stop now if you've if you speak to
countries like the Czech Republic or
representatives of in Poland they have
very specific living memory of invasions
from Russia and the former Soviet Union
so this is felt very pungently there so
we need to make sure that we secure our
borders once again it is a good
investment and the thing about the the
quote from the Kremlin there is we're
very used to the rhetoric from the
Kremlin now and we have to take it into
that uh that perspective now the deems
at harway we know of course there's
going to be an inquiry into whether or
not he break the ministerial code I
thought it was interesting I asked Mel
strides uh what happens if he's found to
be in breach will she see you next slack
him and he said I think that would be a
very difficult finding not exactly a
rigging endorsement do you think there
is a possibility that he could stay on
at those circumstances well we know that
there is a possibility because this is
the territory party we're talking about
you know we had free to Patel who broke
the ministerial code and she wasn't
sanctioned in any way shape or form we
know that other ministers have broken
the ministerial code and there's no
sanction so what's happened and this is
the thing that worries me the most about
Nadine zahawi other than the the issue
within its Singularity is the fact that
once again people are looking on a
government and they're looking on at
Parliament and they're just saying they
were all the same I mean I guess what
Russia sunak would say is that look he's
a different person to Boris Johnson you
know the examples you give went under
his Premiership
what I want to see is is action not
words I mean what Boris Johnson would
have done is exactly the same as Rishi
sunak by hiring Gavin Williamson putting
him in post when everybody knew he was
not fit for that office and he wouldn't
last long and he's going there is now 24
allegations against the Justice
secretary uh Dominic Robb this is
according to the guardian according to
the guardian yeah this evening you know
and that's rumbling on then we have the
issues with Sue Ella brabham and sacked
and then rehired six days later you know
no other this is unrecognizable to any
other Walk of Life than what we're
seeing here is unrecognizable to me in
the labor party this is one this is only
recognizable behavior in one part of our
political landscape and that's the Tory
party well we'll have a look we'll have
to find out what does happen and of
course they want to pre-judge the
report's findings thanks very much
really interesting to talk to you today
please come
you're watching the takeaway live view
in Westminster this evening up next
we're going to take a closer look at
today's prime minister's questions
[Music]
foreign
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take now time to
take a closer look at this lunchtime's
prime minister's questions now as you
can imagine the PM took plenty of
incoming fire from Kirsten Dean zahawi's
taxes Skies Ali Fortescue has been
taking a look at all the action from The
Commons pmqs unwrapped is next
it was billed as a box office pmqs a
moment of political Peril for a PM
defending a cabinet minister Under Fire
but instead the hall fell silent as a
labor leader opened with a question
about the murder of Zara Alina
opportunities were missed by the
probation service that could have
prevented this attack and saved her life
does the Prime Minister accept those
findings
Mr Speaker this was a truly terrible
crime
and as the Chief Inspector has found the
failings in this case and indeed others
were serious and indeed unacceptable
but it was a pmqs of two halves the mood
turned and the noise in the chamber
returned as a labor leader moved to
Nadim zahawi's tax affairs
just the Prime Minister agree
that any politician who seeks to avoid
the taxes they owe in this country is
not fit to be in charge of taxpayer
money
well Mr Speaker I'm pleased to make my
position on this matter completely clear
to the house
[Applause]
really interesting was a contrast with
last week where the PM tried to brush a
controversy aside my honorable friend
has already addressed this matter in
full and there's nothing more that I can
add Brushy Scenic defending Nadim zahawi
but listen to him this week the issues
in question occurred before I was prime
minister
[Applause]
with regard to the appointment of the
minister without portfolio the usual
appointments process was followed no
issues no issues were raised with me
no defense whatsoever there's cabinet
colleague this week instead Rishi sunak
effectively said he's not to blame for
whatever happens next what kirstama
wants to do is make this not just about
Nadeem zahawi but Rishi sunak himself
the labor leader again pushed the attack
that the PM is weak his failure to sack
him when the whole country could see
what's going on shows how hopelessly
weak he is
he starting to wonder if this job is
just too big for him
[Applause]
and Rishi sunak also fell back onto Old
attack lines with yet another reference
to kirstama's predecessor when I
disagree fundamentally with the previous
prime minister I resigned from the
government but before but for four but
for four long years he sat next to the
member for Islington North
foreign
benches became more animated I know he
reads from these prepared sheets but he
should listen to what I actually said
look at Labor here accusing the PM of
not reading his own notes then came
another personal swipe from the smp's
Stephen Flynn what advice would he have
for individuals seeking to protect their
personal finances should they seek out
our future chair of the BBC to help
secure an 800 000 pounds loan
should they set up a trust in Gibraltar
and hope that hmrc simply don't notice
or should they do as others have done
and simply apply for non-dom status
[Music]
there were familiar insults but no real
killer blow on a day like today the PM's
team will be pleased that more damage
wasn't inflicted and hope that some of
the heat in the zahawi route may have
passed for now
there talking about the latest action at
Prime Minister's questions well next
let's return to the plights of 200
children asylum seeking children that we
were speaking about earlier with Peter
Carl unaccompanied minors seeking asylum
in this country that have been housed in
hotels and have gone missing well a
little earlier I spoke to Dame Sarah
Thornton who spent 30 years in the
police and she was Chief Constable of
Thames Valley she was also appointed by
Theresa May to be the independent
anti-slavery commissioner I started by
asking her what had happened
well we know that organized crime groups
will Target vulnerable children and a
company decided seeking children are
vulnerable they're separated from their
families they may have been traumatized
I think it's clear that the traffickers
and the exploiters uh have been
targeting them they know where they are
in the hotels and they're preying on
these children and my my real fear is
that the boys will be locked in cannabis
Farms they may be
um involved in county lines drug
distribution and the girls May well end
up in the sex industry so there's a real
concern about the risk uh of these uh
children and young people
you know to talk about the numbers
involved here almost 200 and you're
talking about the organized crime that
they may be falling into
find it astonishing it's staggering how
is this only coming to light now
so in fact I think there are 440 that
have been reported missing of who 200
are still I'm accounted for that's the
real concern but it does seem to me that
government have been given warnings
about this which they appear to have uh
failed to heed I mean back in the summer
last year in 2022 the home Affairs
committee said the placement of children
in these hotels which is unlawful needed
to stop
the independent Chief Inspector of
borders immigration also raised the
issue back in October he said the hotels
are fine as a crisis response but it
become a core response and it needed to
stop and then the children's charity
epcap made a report last year when there
were 45 missing children now there are
440 so the situation has escalated
children mustn't be placed in these
hotels they need to be properly
supported by local authorities and the
local authorities need to be funded in
order to do so
so actually the answer to my question
why is this only coming to light now is
even more depressing it has been known
for some time but actually the reality
is that no action has been taken who
does the buck stop it's just got worse
and worse
who does the butt stop with who do you
blame
well the
issue is partly caused by the number of
uh people coming across the channel in
small boats and that clearly overwhelmed
um counter Council and they said to the
government we can't continue to provide
the support uh that we should provide
and that's why as an interim measure
there's an emergency measure the home
office uh set up these hotels
but that was 18 months two years ago the
law requires local authorities to
protect and Safeguard children and
that's what needs to happen uh
government needs to work with the local
authorities and needs to make available
adequate funding so they can do it
properly these children are vulnerable
they need to be supported ideally I
think in in foster homes but certainly
in Specialist Care facilities for them
there's a lot of talk in politics about
a so-called hostile environment for
people trying to come to the United
Kingdom
do you worry that some of the impact of
that has been I guess that the system
hasn't cared for some of these miners in
the way that it should have
I think sometimes when you hear people
talk about young galbanian people it's
as if somehow they don't count and
they're not the same as our children you
know the law in this country makes no
differentiation between children on the
basis of their nationality nor indeed
whether they're migrants so an Albanian
child who's 16 years old has all the
rights under the children's act that a
British child would have and I think we
would want to treat children uh in that
way and not differentiating the way that
appears to be happening
um thank you for some really really
powerful words on this case it's
something that I'm very pleased that
we've been able to highlight on the
program today and if I may I did just
want to talk about the death of Zara
Alina now Zara is the law graduate who
was brutally murdered walking home in a
random attack now it's come to like that
herkello was wrongly assessed as medium
risk and opportunities were missed that
could have saved her life
what states is the probation service
currently in
can I just say that I you know an
absolutely horrific murder my heart goes
out to the family and friends of Zara
but I was interested when reading about
this case that the Chief Inspector of
probation talked about systemic issues
in the probation service not only were
there substantial delays in the case
being reviewed it was then given to a
newly qualified probation officer who
assessed the cases as medium and then
after he'd been released from prison he
repeatedly breached his license
conditions and a recall uh was made for
him to be recalled to prison but
unfortunately Zara was murdered before
that could happen and I think it just
points out the fact that if we are going
to release people on license uh before
the end of their sentence then we need a
probation service that is properly
equipped and funded and resourced to
ensure that the public can be publicly
inadequately protected because clearly
in this case Zara was not protected
so do you think that the probation
service isn't being properly funded and
resourced right now
I think that's certainly the case
um in the time when I was a police
officer there were reforms of the
probation service which just appeared to
reduce its capacity and capability to do
the jobs that the staff in the
organization wanted to do and this case
I've heard people interviewed from the
probation service who talk about massive
case loads and how on Earth can a
vibration officer do their job properly
if they're being asked to supervise many
many cases and then when it's not
adequately resourced these awful things
happen has happened to Zara and Lena
yeah that's certainly uh We've certainly
seen the worst possible consequences of
that with her case there's been a lot of
discussion about culture in the police I
just wonder as someone you know who've
obviously been involved in the police in
your time the commissioner Mark Rowley
saying that two or three met police
officers every week expected to be
appearing in court on criminal charges
is the culture rotten
so I think we've all been horrified by
recent cases
um and it does raise serious questions
about the culture because I think you
can't keep on saying it's just One Bad
Apple it's another Bad Apple I do think
that Sir Mark Rowley has got a huge
Challenge on his hands he needs to be
absolutely fearless and robust in
rooting out those people who should not
be police officers but his challenge of
course is he's got to do that at the
same time as maintaining the morale of
all the decent officers who are
committed to public service and he's
also got to have an eye on thinking
about who we're going to recruit in the
future we want to have a Police Service
which people want to join so they too
can help protect the public and serve
the public
did you witness any of this kind of bad
behavior I guess in your time in the
place
when I was first Constable but that's
nearly 40 years ago there was a casual
sexism I guess I mean women got treated
differently would never ever post two
women in a patrol car together and that
was kind of institutionalized uh things
have moved on a long way and I always
used to say and it's seven years since I
left the Police Service in terms of a
police force by the time you achieved
Constable it would take a very brave
person to be directly in openly Sexes
towards you so I you know towards the
end of my service it wasn't an issue but
for sure 30 40 years ago it was part of
the system
yeah this is I mean I know it's a very
different culture but certainly in
Westminster as well like everything that
I've experienced has been right at the
beginning of my career where I guess
people treat women very differently in
the different roles that they hold uh
it's been really interesting to talk
thank you so much for giving your view
on a range of subjects today we
appreciate it
uh well we've covered lots of stuff on
the uh program today we'll range of
topics but we've got exam coats with us
and I thought what we might do at the
end is something we haven't done for a
little while which is to take the
temperature of politics right now
because it feels like there's been an
awful lot of stuff that's happened and
I'm just quite intrigued to see if it's
having any impact on the polls what is
the current state of place now well as
we always do we're going to look at the
polls using a pulse that's in the news
at the moment which is you go because of
that of course with the shares from
nothing to Harvey that went into the
trust that's the heart of the rail uh so
let's bring up where the polls are right
at the moment and here we are hopefully
the suspense and we've got labor having
a commanding lead 47 of people say that
they would vote labor in a general
election tomorrow 25 say they were vote
conservances now we are getting close to
50 now that's that's quite close to
quite an important Milestone at the
moment other parties don't need to look
and you need the lib Dem number to be a
little bit higher to get a kind of
landslide worth pointing out a couple of
facts the
um twice as many conservative voters
from 2019 so they now don't know and
we'll switch the switch later that's a
one thing that the Tories still to have
to hang on to that there are large
numbers of don't knows but the trend
look at the next slide is absolutely
dreadful for the conservatives here you
have the conservative win the election
and you see this blue line ultimately
Crossing there uh at the end of 2021 and
now Richard Cena came into Downing
Street here in November and there has
been no bounce there has been no Bounce
has been uh uh labor holding steady all
the way through uh since and I think at
this point really really uh what you
haven't seen is the Tories taking off
this year now the other thing that
Tories point to is our next slide and
that is the leader figures and it and it
has seen uh Boris Johnson when he was
leader uh overtaking kirst armor at
points but again you've got Rishi Cena
going in the wrong direction kirstana
going in the in the right direction
Rishi CNAC hasn't managed to get
momentum he had a big announcement last
week 111 projects 2.1 billion pounds
that's a leveling up fund that bike
fired in seek belt gate routes with Tory
MPS what can they do that's right their
mind in sleaze allegations their mind in
Scandal at some point they've got to
even the score Tory MPS are looking at
these numbers looking at all the other
polling that we've got and going when's
it going to get better what do you think
how far very quickly how far do you
think they could go these discrimutorial
piece or is this it to the next solution
um there is no point in changing leader
before the next election so all they can
do is Grumble and many of them don't
like British soon actually they probably
will and lots of gambling uh probably
not exactly what Richard Cenac needs
that if he is to try and turn some of
these numbers around as Sam says really
moving in the wrong direction there for
Rishi neck thanks very much Sam always
good to uh chat to you and get your take
well it's been a really busy uh week uh
for us that news of course the headline
news from president zielinski in his
interview with K Burley which can be
shown tomorrow morning at 7 00 a.m for
that full interview thanks very much for
watching we are going to be back next
week and every week Wednesdays at 9 00
PM next up it's guy news at 10. thanks
for watching
[Music]